joining us is rachel mclean she's
minister for safeguarding and and she is
basically a home office
minister um and if you look just down
that lens you can ask her a question
right so my question to you minister is
my energy bills have risen by 80 pounds
a month
and
where used to be 120 pounds is now
200 pounds if not more
um if you include the petrol and things
so i'm just wanting to ask what are you
going to be doing to help people like me
families like me minister
yeah hello it's lovely to speak to you
and we we understand and we know the
impact that rising energy bills and
bills and costs of food are having on
families like yours all over the country
so
we very much do need to make sure that
the support is going to those families
the support packages that we've already
put in place
and we've already put taken action to
help people with energy bills and
there's more help coming
and i think the other point that i think
is really important that families can
i can
take account of is that we have put
money into those local communities who
often know
better than we do in central government
where the need is so
local authorities local areas have got a
household support fund that is available
for families who've got individual
circumstances they might be struggling
and i would definitely recommend any
family who is feeling the pinch at this
time to approach their their local
authority and see what help is on offer
do you want to answer your follow-up um
yeah with what you've just mentioned now
with helpful families that's available
with um within the local council
i also happen to work with with families
from
um
communities experiencing um inequalities
and my question is
if those services are available we are
finding as an organization
that
are
the people we work alongside are not
able to access those
the support that's available because of
the certain boundaries if there's a
requirement of a certain paperwork or if
there's um
forms that needs to be online and they
don't have access to that it's become a
lot more complicated and therefore
people are not um accessing that so my
question is what are you putting in
place for those people that it's so easy
to access as opposed to being so
complicated good question minister i
think that's it's a really good point
and we do recognize that not everybody
has access to the internet and of course
we want to get those funds uh targeted
to where they really need to go as
quickly as possible without excessive
paperwork i mean there has to be some
basic paperwork of course you're talking
about public money and obviously the
government would be criticized if we
didn't take those proportionate steps i
mean i would recommend in your
individual case speak to your local mp i
have this dialogue with my local
organizations often and we are often
able to sign posts and unblock specific
issues that you're having
thank you very much indeed thanks a lot
a minister i'm gonna if i could follow
up on that actually lisa nandy's the
local mp and we will be chatting to her
here in wigan during the course of the
week some of your colleagues think we
should have a government minister for
the cost of living given that inflation
is likely to hit something like 10
percent at least 10 percent we're told
by summit this year do you think that
that is a good idea
so i've not heard that specific request
but what i would say of course that's
the chancellor's job and it's the job of
the whole cabinet and the whole
government and every minister is looking
at particular costs that are impacting
on the areas that they are controlling
and looking to see where savings can be
made and where reductions can be made
because the cost of living is about
energy bills but it's also about all
those other things that you've mentioned
so i think what we need to focus on now
is over the long term we have got these
short-term pressures on us that we're
all aware of and that your families in
wigan are seeing but over the long term
we need to have a plan to grow the
economy and make sure that people are
able to protect themselves better uh
whether that is by taking on more hours
or moving to a better paid job and these
are these are long-term actions but
that's what we're focused on as a
government
you say uh taking on more hours i mean
some people that i've been chatting to
minister over the last i've moved
outside actually because obviously they
need to get ready and get the kids ready
for school you know some people are
working three jobs
they're working um every hour that god
sends them so and they're still going to
food banks um to get to get food because
they can't afford to feed their kids you
know so it's not as straightforward as
that is it
no and of course it's not and
i'm not suggesting that for one moment
but we have often heard in the past when
people are facing problems with their
budgets that one of the obstacles and it
may not be for everybody one of the
obstacles is about being able to take on
more hours or even move to a better paid
job and of course it's an individual
situation depending on on that
particular family situation but that's
why the job centres exist that's why the
work coaches exist that's why we put the
support into those job centres to work
with individuals on their own individual
situation so it may be right for some
people they may be able to access
additional hours but of course it's it's
not going to work for people who are
already
working in three jobs and that's why we
need to have the other measures in place
such as the um all the help that we're
putting into the schools uh the the the
help with the the the um local
authorities help and support that i've
already mentioned and these are where
we're going to target the help where
it's most needed
i'm reading in my telegraph this morning
that
your boss the prime minister is heading
to northern ireland today and he is
blaming the northern ireland protocol on
the cost of living crisis hi
so
so if you read what the prime minister
set out in in that article which i think
is a very
balanced piece
he's making it clear that he needs to go
to northern ireland because we need to
have a functioning executive and that is
how with that strong local leadership
the parties can come together
and tackle the cost of living crisis but
of course the situation is urgent
that's why the prime minister is going
to northern ireland to get around the
table with all those parties to find a
way through this
but explain to me how the northern
ireland protocol is damaging the cost of
living
because what's the situation with the
northern ireland protocol is putting
additional costs and paperwork on
businesses
it's affecting the supply of various
products and of course that has a
knock-on impact on the cost of living
and all of the parties in the recent
elections
have called for changes to be made for
the protocol everyone acknowledges that
it's not working so that's why it is
really important that we see hopefully
we see some movement from the eu but the
prime minister has been clear that
nothing is off the table the situation
needs to be resolved for the benefit of
the peace and security of the people of
northern ireland
i thought it was an oven-ready deal
theresa may we didn't like her deal so
we got a new prime minister boris
johnson told us it was an oven ready
deal and it's an international treaty
i think you're talking about two
different things there we have a trade
and cooperation agreement with our
european partners that was agreed after
the northern ireland protocol was signed
and inherently built into the protocol
is a consent mechanism and requirements
for all parties to work in good faith to
protect those overriding important
principles of the belfast good friday
agreement now clearly there are issues
with how the protocol is working don't
forget it was also signed before kovid
it was signed before a war in ukraine
it is incumbent on all parties to come
together now and and work in good faith
to resolve these practical issues and i
think you know if you look at the
dialogue we've had with the eu we've
been working really hard to put forward
sensible and proportionate proposals to
our eu partners
and we do need to see movement from them
on a number of areas i'll just point to
one uh one particular issue which is
we've we've made proposals and we've set
up um a
an i.t system to ease trade flows and
unfortunately the eu haven't even
implemented that they've not even
started to use it so we've taken a lot
of steps on our side and we really do
want to see that movement now from our
european friends
just to clarify the prime minister is
blaming the situation in ukraine for the
border down the irish sea
no that's not what i said at all i
pointed to a range of factors that have
taken place before
since the protocol was signed and since
the trade and corporation agreement was
negotiated all of which have a bearing
and all parties that are part of this
have a responsibility to the peace and
security of northern ireland
uh but i suppose the um european
government would say we looked at this
we realized it was a bit complicated as
far as the paperwork is concerned and
they say that they've scrapped something
like 80
of the paperwork that was previously
necessary as part of the northern
ireland uh protocol so um who's right is
it british government right or is the
european union right and if we do um
decide that we're going to scrap parts
of the northern ireland protocol are you
content that it would be within the law
and you would vote for it
so i think on your first point of course
there are always going to be measures
that have to be negotiated and i think
that's the whole that's the point of a
negotiation with our european partners
this has been going on at pace with
officials with our with our
interlocutors uh on the european side
and as far as the uh subsequent actions
that are going to be taken
a lot of it is speculation but of course
the uk is a country that always lives up
to its international legal obligations
and we will continue to do that
okay just before i let you go minister i
know that you're very busy this morning
we appreciate you taking the time and i
know that mickey appreciates you
answering her questions um i can see
that there are some suggestions that uh
civil servant numbers should be uh cut
in and around uh white hole some 200
miles south of where we are now perhaps
something like 20 in the home office
will the home office still uh work
effectively with a 20 cut in staff i
think it's always right to look at where
taxpayers money is being spent including
on the civil service and i know from my
time in government that we have added
more people rightly so to help us get
through not only the kovid pandemic but
also those brexit negotiations it's
always right to keep those numbers under
review what we're seeing
in a number of government departments is
actually moving them out of london so
they are closer to the communities such
as wicked and i think that's a really
positive step
okay it's good to talk to you minister
thanks very much indeed for joining us
thanks a lot